370
60 60
900
by texting sky
to 70150
to give 10 pounds
or by sending a check to this address
just 10 pounds provides essential
hygiene supplies for one displaced
person for a month
50 pounds means blankets for 10 homeless
people in freezing temperatures
and 100 pounds can provide emergency
food for two families
for a whole month
they need our help to survive
[Music]
please
donate now
[Music]
it is seven o'clock this is sky news
live from levi ukraine with a special
program on the ukraine invasion on the
eighth day of this conflict
mario poll in southeast ukraine is
encircled and under siege from russian
invaders the mayor of the city describes
it as genocide
russian forces advance into the southern
city of person but both sides claim to
have control
russia is accused by ukrainian ministers
of war crimes but putin insists his
campaign is going according to plan
special military operation is being
conducted strictly in accordance to the
plan and schedule
[Music]
united in defiance hundreds of ukrainian
mps meet in secret for just 10 minutes
and sign off new laws to arm the
resistance
tens of thousands of refugees continue
to stream into neighboring countries the
un says more than a million people have
fled so far
speeding up sanctions new curbs to crack
down on russian oligarchs linked to
president putin
[Music]
and good evening from la viv in the west
of ukraine just over a week on from the
start of the russian invasion life for
the people of this country is getting
more difficult cities in the south are
being bombarded mario paul appears to be
under siege and coming under heavy
attack and its mayor has described it as
genocide in kiev the nervous wait for
continues as a russian convoy wait on
the outskirts of that city
let's take you through the day's key
developments on the ground here and
ukraine says mariopol
is under pretty constant attack now the
city's mayor says russia has
deliberately cut rail links to prevent
civilians evacuating the city has no
water or power supply
to the west is kerson which russia now
says is under its complete control a
claim disputed by ukrainian sources and
close by there's a battle underway for
control of enerhoda home to europe's
largest nuclear plant uh that's
according to the local mayor there well
in chernohev ukraine's emergency
services say 22 bodies have been
recovered so far after a russian
airstrike hit two schools and houses
earlier today
in the capital kiev mps gathered in
secret today for just 10 minutes to
approve laws allowing the seizure of a
russian-owned asset and the right of
citizens to bear arms and in the second
city of kharkiv
while it's seeing its uh shelling
continue with much of the center of the
city now reduced to rubble alex rossi
has our first report tonight on the
battle for the cities
as this war gets uglier russia's tactics
are becoming more violent and
destructive
this video from chernhiv shows a missile
strike on a residential apartment block
the blast wave shakes the entire city
whilst the building burns emergency
workers rescue days civilians
and the situation in other parts of the
country is just as desperate
this is borijanka but as these pictures
show it could just as easily be a suburb
in syria the damage goes on as far as
the eye can see
what do you want from us
go away from our land you don't want to
leave now
sit down with me at the negotiation
table i'm available sit with me but not
at 30 meters like you welcome macron and
schultz and others i'm your neighbor you
don't need to keep me at 30 meter
distance i don't bite
i'm a normal man sit down with me let's
talk what are you afraid
on the south coast mariopol is now
surrounded by russian forces there's a
constant barrage of artillery smashing
into this city on the sea of azov
civilians have been trapped for days
basic essentials running out in many
places
the mayor says even those fleeing have
come under attack
they've been shooting at moving vehicles
a humanitarian convoy couldn't even
leave the surrounding areas of our town
today we're in a blockade and to create
tension in the town they're shooting in
the residential areas targeting
civilians elderly people children to
create internal panic
and in some places russian troops and
tanks are now in control the man
recording these images of the invading
force is clearly trapped and very
frightened
i think i should stop recording before
someone shoots me on my hand
the southern port city of kersen is the
first to fall to vladimir putin's forces
leaving people fearful about what the
violent takeover will mean
it's
like very scary because we hear a lot of
explosions especially at night and early
in the morning
and we're trying not to leave because
i'm here with my grandmother now and
we have enough food for couple weeks
ukraine though has no intention of
surrender even in places that have been
overcome russian soldiers have been
jeered and confronted by ordinary people
in this eastern town which has
supposedly been pacified a russian
soldier carries two grenades after a
meeting with the mayor to ensure he's
not attacked by the crowds
and despite the intensifying brutality
this is a nation that remains united and
defiant
ukrainian mps gather to send a message
to the kremlin in parliament
we had to call to vote for the
mobilization for taking out russian
assets
for bearing arms for
collaborationism
and
for informational security like for
other for many others many many things
[Music]
they are singing the national anthem
but their words are being heard far
beyond the walls of this chamber
alex rossi sky news eastern ukraine
let me just uh bring you some breaking
news now and the government has
announced sanctions against uh
a couple of russian oligarchs alicia
uzmanov and igor shivalov
they include a full asset freeze a
travel ban imposed
against uh usmanov and sugarloft two of
russia's leading oligarchs with
significant interests uh in the uk
and close links to the kremlin uh
usmanov has had significant interests in
english football clubs uh arsenal and
everton uh he had interest in he owns a
beechwood house in highgate worth an
estimated 48 million and the 16th
century sutton place
estate in surrey
shivalov's assets in the uk include
two luxury apartments in central london
worth an estimated 11 million
he is also a core part of putin's inner
circle and headed up russia's bid
for the 2018
world cup
now as we've been saying there's been
heavy shelling in the strategic port
city of mario pole which appears
now to be encircled with civilians
trapped by intense shelling
a 40-mile long russian convey
remains on the outskirts of kiev let's
get more now on the latest movements of
russian troops and the areas they may be
targeting next kamali melbourne was
joined by the security and defense
analyst michael clark
so as we know the russians are in a
number of positions around ukraine just
tell us where we are on day eight
yes kamali i mean day eight um
it's it's a two-front war there is a
northern front where the russians are
trying to surround kiev and move in to
actually remove the government and a
southern front where they're going for
territory
and eventually those northern and
southern fronts they would hope uh will
actually link up they're surrounding
cities now that's the stage around so
chunahiv sumi
are all surrounded as are the big cities
in the south yes it's a fight for the
cities of the north but you mentioned
the cities in the south and as we know
in the past day or so uh the city of
kerason in the south has as we
understand it fall into the russians
just explain to us the importance of
these cities we can see odessa there
question mario paul these cities for the
ukrainians yeah three big cities out
mario paul should have fallen within
hours of the assault beginning day eight
uh there's no water no electricity
they're still hanging on i don't know
how they're doing it but they are uh
surrounded kirschen uh taken and
surrounded uh there is still some fight
incursion and odessa increasingly looks
as if it is going to be surrounded and
odessa of course is the port uh taking
odessa which i'm sure the russians will
try to do will be economically
disastrous for ukraine yeah and we have
seen some footage coming out from the
last couple of hours that shows some
ships off the coast of crimea now what
do they tell us about what may well be
happening next well there's more than 30
odd uh major battleships russian
battleships in the black sea at least
seven of them are missile carrying ships
three submarines but among that group
there are six assault ships five
standard ones one very big one those
assault ships normally carry about 12
tanks maybe 36 armored personnel
carriers and they carry about 300 troops
so five or six of those is quite a punch
to actually deliver if they're all going
to be used together in preparation for
an amphibious assault one would assume a
an amphibious assault on odessa is
probably the next step okay michael
clark thank you very much
well in an address to his security
council vladimir putin has described
russians and ukrainians as one people
and he also insisted that his strategy
is going to plan earlier his foreign
minister sergey lavrov accused america
of acting like napoleon or hitler and
justified the invasion by calling
ukraine's desire to join nato a threat
to russian security
meanwhile the kremlin continues efforts
to suppress dissent stifling independent
journalism and warning people that any
unsanctioned protesting
could lead to a prison sentence uh
moscow correspondent diana magnay
reports now on the changing nature of
putin's plan
the funeral of a russian soldier one of
so many killed during vladimir putin's
bloody advance through ukraine
we all still hope for the better that
everyone starts alive and everyone comes
home healthy alive back home
but they won't because their president
is determined to keep on fighting
committed to his own twisted narrative
that this is a battle against the
neo-nazi regime despite the fact that
ukraine's president is jewish
ukraine i will never go back on the
statement that russians and ukrainians
are one people even though a lot of
ukrainians have been threatened and
brainwashed
we are fighting with the neo-nazis
they are using civilians as human
shields
those comments at a meeting with his
security council where he held a
moment's silence for russia's dead
it follows a phone call with the french
president which a french presidential
source said contained nothing reassuring
their description of that call is one of
the grimmest i've ever read vladimir
putin said he was fighting a neo-nazi
regime and that unless diplomatically
ukraine was disarmed and neutralized he
would continue his military campaign
president macron told him that this was
not a nazi regime that he was deluded
and not describing reality and that it
would cost his country dearly the source
said that vladimir putin intended to
take the whole country and that the
worst was yet to come
but russia is shrugging off the blame
for this war even as it bans its own
media from calling it once
the thing is the west is listening to us
but he's not hearing us and it's trying
to impose in every possible way it's
understanding of how to live in europe
this begs comparisons at the time
napoleon and hitler had an objective to
have the whole of europe under their
control now americans have the whole of
europe under their control
europe is not under america's control
and neither is ukraine but those words
spring from a mindset deeply held
amongst a small group in the kremlin
which will cost ukraine europe and
russia dearly for a long long time to
come
diana magnay sky news moscow
well now the un refugee agency says the
number of people fleeing ukraine is uh
the fastest exodus seen anywhere in the
world this century the un says that well
over a million people have escaped to
neighboring countries since the conflict
began with that number rising by the
hour some 90 000 have already traveled
into western europe but the largest
number
has crossed the border into poland
that's more than
and 550 thousand
nearly a hundred and forty thousand have
gone to hungary which has changed its uh
hard-line policy on accepting refugees
moldova which is not a member of nato
and is nervous it could suffer the same
fate as ukraine has received nearly 100
000 people over 79 000 have crossed into
slovakia and romanian authorities have
told sky news today that more than 150
000 people have arrived from ukraine
aleister bunker reports from the
romanian town of siret just south of the
ukrainian border
the stream of refugees crossing the
border now is almost constant and it's
increasing all the time
it is snowing here it is bitterly cold
but at least it's safe
almost everyone has left someone behind
decisions they'll never forget
i leave my family
i leave my mom
mom
was crying and telling me that
that maybe she never see me again
it was
it was small scary words which i
hear it in my life
i'm still
i'm still scared i'm still afraid that
i can't
can't see her anymore
i'm left behind of my life i left behind
all my dreams
for a few there is sheer relief at being
reunited with family
most though arrived dazed unsure of
what's next
i hope we will win soon
the war will end and we come home again
at the moment the authorities here are
coping there is enough food there is
enough shelter there's enough help
but what if the numbers double triple
quadruple even it's fair to say that at
the moment
the romanians have kind of got it sorted
it's a pretty good operation they they
move people here
as quick as they can do there's food hot
food
drinks for them they process them
buses free buses and then into the local
towns and villages
but the numbers are getting more
it was eight percent more refugees
yesterday than the day before that
and there's already been more today
again
on one side of the border there are
humans killing humans
just the other side humans helping
humans
there is something quite life-affirming
in the way eastern europeans are doing
everything they can to look after their
neighbours
alice debunk the sky news on the
ukrainian romanian border
deborah haynes is uh still with me here
in la viv so deborah these humanitarian
corridors that are being talked about
after these talks in belarus tonight
could they be significant i don't think
we should read too much into it because
the ukrainians went into these talks
wanting a complete ceasefire their
cities are being pulverized and they
have been for the last eight days their
their military has managed to slow the
russian advance but this is a relentless
russian force and they have more more
backup
they clearly have more firepower and as
they are becoming frustrated in terms of
the speed of their operation then
they're using more indiscriminate fire
and that's what we're seeing in these
cities like such as mario paul the mayor
today saying that he can't even get the
wounded out so that's why these
humanitarian corrupt corridors are vital
to in terms of
averting what's already a crisis but at
least trying to rescue some of the
civilians but they're saying there's
only the possibility of there being a
temporary ceasefire in orbit in order to
enable that and then saying that there
will be further talks but in terms of
any kind of shining light
to see that there might be some hope for
some kind of compromise that could end
the violence we're very far from that at
the moment right but a small mercy maybe
yes and more generally vladimir putin
and his
state of mind we've we've heard from him
tonight national address we've heard
from his spokeswoman tonight um you know
what are you reading into all this
it's it's very easy isn't it for us sort
of western
countries which he treats with such
disdain and we view moscow as such we
view comments from moscow with such
suspicion there is this huge divide at
the moment and it's becoming entrenched
and the rhetoric the language coming
from the kremlin coming from the top
from president putin it does not reflect
reality it doesn't matter what kind of
west or east position you're in there is
only one reality and when president
putin goes on television and accuses
the president zadenski of heading some
neo-nazi regime seeking nuclear weapons
and holding foreigners hostage and using
them as human shields it's not the
reality when his foreign foreign
ministry spokeswoman tells our
correspondent dominic waghorn that
civilian casualties are fake news that
the explosions that you're seeing is
fake it's just not the reality but it's
from the one in kharkiv specifically
a cruise missile strike on a government
building as as dominic rightly said
that's not a military target or not an
obvious one at least um but this react
this alternate reality that the russian
audience is being fed is very dangerous
because it entrenches those two
positions and in terms of the war you
asked about that with what president
putin was saying we heard from president
macron today who had a conversation with
the russian leader and he was told that
the plan is to take the whole of ukraine
and there's there's the worst movie to
come worse to come and and also the fact
that um president macron warned
president putin that he was made making
a major mistake warned him that the
language he was using in terms of
describing the ukrainian government as
being neo-nazi was delusional and yet
there is that huge disconnect president
putin either believes this fantasy
or believes that maintaining this
fantasy is sufficient to justify the
actions that he's taking either way it's
bad news for ukraine's people and the
whole the country as a whole yeah and it
does not bode well uh deborah thank you
very much indeed
well what about ukraine's president well
uh he was uh well he's challenged the
russian president putin to sit down for
talks while urging the west to offer a
stronger military assistance to ukraine
to fight the russian invasion let's hear
what he said at a news conference in the
capital this afternoon
go away from our land if you don't want
to go away sit down at the table of
negotiations i am available sit down but
not 30 meters away like you did with
macron schultz etc i'm your neighbor you
don't need to keep me 30 minutes away
from you i don't bite i'm a
well nbc's uh chief foreign
correspondent richard engel was at that
news conference and uh i spoke to him a
little earlier
i was surprised first of all that he
agreed to have this small gathering with
reporters considering the security
constraints that he is under
but he is in kiev we met at a government
building and there were probably 15 20
different journalists in the room
he arrived without a massive security
entourage he did have security with him
but he was carrying his own chair he put
it down in front of the room
he sat down he appeared calm relaxed
in good humor he made some some jokes he
did look a little tired he said he's
only been getting a few hours of sleep
per night
but he seemed determined determined to
continue to lead this country
he's making a a plea for more help
specifically he wants a no-fly zone
he emphasized once again that he
believes that vladimir putin will not
stop at ukraine that he will continue to
go through eastern europe and he said
that he will continue his offensive
until he reaches the berlin wall so he
he
truly believes that vladimir putin is on
a mission to
relitigate the cold war with force and
with a different outcome for vladimir
putin
he also mentioned that this country
needs more weapons so he he he made the
appeal for dialogue with putin a no-fly
zone and weapons but he he did seem
quite quite calm and i and i would say
even in in good spirits
nbc's richard engel speaking to me a
little earlier this is sky news tonight
uh coming up
athletes from russia and belarus are
banned from the winter paralympics after
protests from other nations at the games
[Music]
i'm never lazarus and i'm skies reporter
based in delhi
we take you to the heart of the story
that shapes our world
[Music]
[Music]
ukrainian government is confirming that
they are now engaged with russia's
soldiers
air raid sirens fill the airways in the
distance artillery rains down it feels
very close to the center oh
there's one they found this devastation
to their apartment
lots of people live here quite a few of
the windows of the houses have been
blown out by the blast
and it feels that it's changing each day
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome back to ukraine russia has been
further excluded from international
sport because of its invasion of this
country it will not be allowed to host a
formula one for the foreseeable future
and russian and bella russian athletes
have been banned from the winter
paralympics which start in beijing
tomorrow in a last-minute u-turn the
international paralympic committee was
heavily criticized when it initially
said it would allow the athletes to
compete as neutrals but after a public
outcry it's changed its mind our sports
correspondent tom parmenter reports now
on pressure at the paralympics
three words that just don't go together
neutral athlete russia
the paralympic organizers thought that
it could work but almost everyone else
here was saying no
the wheelchair curlers from latvia were
among the first to refuse to play the
russians you can feel the tension
it's it's hard to explain but when you
see someone from the you know russian
paralympic committee you know that there
is this war happening and you know that
they probably are not supporting it but
they are not speaking openly about it as
well
with a growing rebellion the paralympic
organizers had to change their minds
the deaths in ukraine were staring right
at them after a journalist showed them
the story of a 19 year old who competes
in biathlon for ukraine who was killed
this week in the battle for kharkiv at
the end of the day
this is not on the ipc this is on russia
uh the ipc shouldn't be having to deal
with this i mean what country who
co-sponsors an olympic truce
like bombs
like
everywhere in a massive country the
russian paralympic team said the
decision was illegal and wrong
the ukrainians who are also here
naturally welcomed it some of their 20
athletes and support team had to escape
the bombing to reach beijing
the front line is back home
and
our military are defending this front
line from the aggressor
from the invader but our front
for us is here in beijing this is where
we fight at the part of the games
by removing athletes from russia and
belarus these games can at least carry
on
this was
i think the only decision the ipc could
take in terms of allowing the least
amount of friction at the games
uh i feel so sorry for the athletes from
belarus and from russia on a personal
level
but um what putin is doing
can't go without challenge
and so these games can at least now get
underway the horror and politics of war
will not be forgotten in beijing but
they won't stop everyone else from
taking part
tom parmenter sky news
now developments in satellite technology
mean that the war in ukraine is visible
to millions of people in a way that
hasn't been seen before in a global
conflict images such as the russian
convoy headed for kiev were first picked
up by google maps and could be openly
viewed not just
by the military but by ordinary citizens
it means people have access to images
beyond the control of governments who
maybe want to keep them out of the
public eye
science correspondent thomas more
reports now on how new technology is
helping analysis
of the conflict from space
it's satellites that can be as small as
a shoe box that are giving us a view of
a conflict zone we've never had before
these are nano satellites being
assembled in glasgow and soon to join a
constellation of more than 100 already
in orbit listening in to signals from
ships and aircraft they spotted the
russian navy and the black sea switch
off tracking beacons just before the
invasion so by shrinking satellites down
and miniaturizing the technology so
these small satellites are more capable
you can deploy them more cost
effectively but what you can also do is
deploy many more of them
slightly larger commercial satellites
are providing the crisp images of
convoys damaged airfields and bombed
buildings their cameras are so good they
can spot objects just 30 centimeters
across even catching a missile being
launched and with so many satellites in
orbit it's possible to monitor the same
area several times a day
the military has had access to that kind
of detail for many years but the ukraine
conflict has launched it into the public
domain open source intelligence from
small satellites is giving us an
independent eye on what's going on and
then once you have training data even an
ageing satellite owned by the european
space agency can lead to surprising
discoveries this general purple
background is what we would expect to
get back from the satellite these
lighter blue
splotches are
something on the ground a military radar
most likely causing interference
it's a training exercise in belarus just
before the invasion and the scientist
has now written radar detection software
so anyone can search images from the
sentinel satellite in the conflicts that
i've lived through you know the invasion
of iraq and and all of that
the only imagery that came out of it
were the images that were being released
by the us department of defense uh and
and you just kind of had to take their
word for it you know
now anyone with an internet connection
can check for themselves but even if
governments can no longer control what
we see the images can still be used to
shape public perception from a
propaganda point of view uh nato could
use this in terms of say this is what
the russians are doing specifically to
um uh
prove that the russians are not telling
the truth about uh this conflict by
being able to use uh public available
images uh they can turn around and say
hey this is this is uh this is what's
happening you can see it for yourself
two
one
but satellites are giving us eyes and
ears on parts of ukraine beyond the
reach of tv cameras and civilians with
mobile phones the horror of war is being
seen from above thomas more sky news
glasgow
this is a sky news a ukraine invasion
special coming up has
britain done enough to seize the wealth
of russian oligarchs
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to la viv in ukraine
two russian oligarchs have tonight been
sanctioned by the foreign office
restricting their ability to carry out
any financial transaction in the uk they
are billionaire alicia usmanov who has
links to everton football club and
former russian deputy prime minister
igor shivalov who was named by
kierstarma in parliament yesterday
under parliamentary privilege
we're joined now by dr alina polyakova
from the center for european policy
analysis and also by misha gleny a
journalist and author of the
mafia book about eastern european
organized crime thank you very much both
for being with me this evening misha
first of all
are these two the sorts of
people that the government should be
going after
uh i think definitely their track record
is is fairly clear
both osmanov and shubalov
um
have been
closely engaged with putin for a
very long time it's slightly surprising
that it took us this long to
to to get there britain appeared to take
the lead
on engaging with the sanctioning of
oligarchs earlier this week about a week
or so ago and then they started to drag
their feet and the european union
actually took the lead and of course
yesterday it was
uh
absolutely
extraordinary yacht i mean it looked it
looks like a um
it looks like a cruise liner uh was uh
seized in hamburg so the germans were on
it and uh yes these are the sort of
people who are very close to putin and
whose
relationship involves not only uh
political engagement but uh probably
financial engagement as well
and anna a
simple question really does sanctioning
oligarchs
work does it have the desired impact
well i think it depends on what we mean
by work i mean it's certainly very
disruptive to putin's inner circle and
we have to remember that russia isn't
around like a democratic country like
the uk or the united states or others
it's really run by a sort of clan and
some people that belong to that clan are
in government some are outside the
government and certainly they're all
intertwined from a financial perspective
and we don't know exactly how but every
time we hit
one of these high level close members
a deep part of this clan
it will reverberate and have effects on
others including mr putin most likely
and certainly um i think in the longer
term it may make some of these
individuals a bit more reticent about
supporting mr putin's policies if he can
no longer guarantee
their access to their own wealth and
their financial assets which has been
the basis uh really of their support for
mr putin for all these years
misha what do you make of abramovich
the chelsea owner
you know he's
clearly disposing of his assets there
will other oligarchs be doing
uh similar things
uh yes i i believe so and a lot of them
will have been working on this for um
a little time even before the invasion i
i i would have thought uh i mean you
noticed with abramovic
that
he has said that he will give the
proceeds of the chelsea sale
to um
to victims of the ukrainian war he
doesn't say whether they're russian or
ukrainian victims but um
it's it's a gesture which we're seeing
amongst some of the oligarchs who are
clearly hedging their bets about what's
going to happen in the future and i
think there's an important
important message here
to put across that um with all of the
sanctions they don't just hit oligarchs
they're also hitting the russian people
as well very very severely already in a
short space of time and i think the
message is is to send out that
these are not designed to hurt the
russian people per se
they are designed to put pressure on the
economic and political elite and
particularly those
around putin and that they're two
different things because if we if we
accept that this is a highly
undemocratic society and particularly in
the last week i think that um putin has
gone full north korea in many many
respects including in the media then we
also have to expect that the russian
people don't actually know what's going
on really in ukraine to a large degree
so it is important to target uh
individuals
not to say that we are targeting the
russian people as a whole because they
happen to be russians
and
dr pollyakova why does it
or seems why is it that it seems that
sanctioning oligarchs takes
such a long time what is the process
that needs to
be gone through and is it i suppose part
of it is proving you know some sort of
link to putin
well it's certainly incredibly
complicated these individuals of course
don't hold their assets or their money
in their own name
there's an incredibly complex system of
shell companies and other means of
hiding wealth that spreads across their
family members spreads across
acquaintances and it's really uncovering
this uh dark web of corruption that is
the key and that is why i think the the
white house um in the united states as
well as allies are taking the right step
by establishing a task force uh to be
able to track down and enforce these
sanctions not just on these individuals
but what's really important here i think
it was actually quite new in this round
of sanctions than what we've seen
previously is that they are also
targeting close family members of course
these people have property all over the
world they have in all kinds of hidden
offshore accounts and i think we have to
aggressively track these down shut them
down so they start to hit really hard as
individuals at home and certainly there
will be effects from broader sanctions
not these sanctions on the russian
people but i think what's really
interesting to watch now is that most of
the effects are now happening from
companies uh american companies uk
companies uh european companies from
pulling out of the russian market even
though they are not being forced to but
the sanctions regime is making it
difficult for them to operate there and
just today we saw iran on ikea happening
in saint petersburg because ikea
announced they will no longer operate in
russia so i think these kinds of
second-tier facts are actually what's
needed to start to really make it clear
to the russian people that their
government has been lying to them and
that they unfortunately are going to
have to bear some of those costs
because of the kremlin's
brutal war against ukraine
right and misha what about these
you know wealthy russians who are giving
money to the
conservative party i mean
not necessarily
would they have close connections to
putin i suppose
no not necessarily but you have to
understand
why
this uh
this sort of environment has emerged in
the first place and that's why it's
really important when we do this is not
just to target russians but to target
the mechanisms which successive british
governments have actually facilitated
so that people from all over the world
can turn london into the the money
laundering capital
um of the world and with regards the
tory party i think we should really
start to scrutinize
where the wealth of those people who
donated to the tory party actually came
from if you look for example evgeny
levitef who was enobled of course by
boris johnson despite the house of lords
appointments committee arguing against
that um uh that ennoblement because of
uh
this was after they'd received
information from from mi6 about lebanese
is
you know um are we looking at uh money
that was made legitimately in the 1990s
by his father or was there some uh
dodgy stuff in operation there we just
we have to look at all this stuff if you
look at the um
the house of
commons select committee from 2018 on
security and intelligence
the uh report told russia that uh boris
johnson tried to kick in the long grass
and postpone its um publication until
after the election in 2019 if you look
at that there are two clear messages
that came out of that first of all the
tories receive a lot of money from
russians
secondly
um the house of common select committee
believed there was sufficient evidence
to examine what the russian involvement
in the brexit referendum of 2016 was so
there are all sorts of questions which
emerge out of this whether they're
actually going to be examined properly
um i don't know i don't hold out a huge
amount to hope
okay and just finally dr polyakova
you think i was
reading uh earlier today that you think
that institutions
like museums and so forth need to be
careful about accepting money from
oligarchs going forward
absolutely you know we have seen this
pattern emerge over the last uh 20 years
where
these russian oligarchs who are
getting wealthy by stealing from the
russian people through corruption are
whitewashing their reputations by being
listed on the boards of trustees of
incredibly prestigious cultural
institutions um you know guggenheim
being one but many many others
and you know maybe there was an excuse
for that 20 years ago 15 years ago when
we didn't really know the true nature of
the regime these individuals look like
maybe legitimate businessmen but now
that we have uh a war
in europe a completely unprovoked
aggression from russia every one of
these oligarchs has been complacent in
this war
all of their businesses um because
they're wealth begotten in all kinds of
corrupt ways has been supporting this
regime so i think now is the time to
offload this money by nonprofit
institutions or cultural institutions to
send a clear message of no more because
the picture is a little too crystal
clear now and frankly i don't think you
want to be in a position as one of these
uh highbrow cultural institutions where
suddenly you find yourself uh listing on
your board of trustees someone who's
been sanctioned by the united states or
the uk or europe i mean there's a huge
reputational risk there and i don't
think it's worth it
yeah it's an interesting point uh dr
pollyakova and also misha gleny thank
you both very much indeed
thank you
right this is a sky news ukraine special
coming up the uk launches a massive aid
appeal to help the ukrainian people
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
i'm david blevins and i'm skye's senior
ireland correspondent
[Music]
i'm based in belfast a city transformed
by peace but still struggling with its
past
politically the two sides are as far
apart as ever and it's over that
question of who has sovereignty in
northern ireland the very issue that's
been the source of tension here for
generations
it takes 60 minutes to cross the irish
sea
it took the british monarchy a century
i've spent 25 years reporting the
journey from conflict to peace
the political parties of northern
ireland have reached agreement
we help you understand the world with us
today
we have reached an agreement with the
conservative party on support for
government in parliament
we already know what the government gets
out of this deal what exactly does the
dup get out of it well 1.5 billion
pounds
welcome to winterfell it's an iconic
location in this globally acclaimed
drama
ophelia was the most powerful hurricane
this far east in the atlantic on record
you can't live in a place like this and
not appreciate the environment
welcome back to ukraine a national
fundraising campaign has been launched
tonight to help
this country the disasters emergency
committee is appealing for funds to help
people affected by
this conflict already the government has
donated
some medical equipment and other
humanitarian supplies another plane
carrying tons
of aid left stance at airport
near london earlier today
well tonight's appeal is led by the
disaster
emergency committee the government says
it will match every donation up to a
total of 20 million pounds we're joined
now by the chief executive of the
disasters emergency committee salah
saheed thank you very much for joining
us and
as we've been seeing
on sky news all day the need
is really very very acute now
indeed it is mark and we've seen the
news today that one million people have
sadly
fled the conflict in ukraine has crossed
the borders into neighboring countries
such as poland and romania and the needs
as your program is already highlighted
are immense people leaving their homes
their livelihoods their jobs and often
their families behind and the pictures
are showing now the kind of scale that
we're having to deal with
and the dec the disasters emergency
committee launches appeal today united
with its 15
member charities both working directly
on the ground and through local partners
and of course we must also
credit and acknowledge the wonderful
work that local volunteers and the
ukrainian
charities and of course the charities on
the border as well are responding as the
first responders and our member
charities
and their local partners are working
alongside them to make sure that we
reach as many people as possible that's
why the dec has launched the appeal
today
and i was going to ask you about what
you were just talking about i mean how
easy is it or perhaps i should say how
difficult is it to get
aid into ukraine on the ground
now must be very difficult
the logistics of working in a war zone
is always difficult and challenging and
of course the considerations for the
safety of aid workers and civilians for
that matter as well but we are working
with the the 13 leading
international aid organizations who are
used to working in conflict zones in war
zones and
have appropriate systems and protocols
in place to make sure both the safety of
their aid workers and their and their
volunteers the real challenge is of
course the scale of the need and making
sure that there is sufficient funds in
order to meet that need the united
nations has estimated that it needs 1.5
billion us dollars in order to meet that
humanitarian response and we're
incredibly grateful to the uk public
when that first day of the appeal
already responding hugely general
generously by donating on our phones on
our website and we of course urge people
to continue to support the appeal so
that we can reach even more people in
ukraine and in surrounding countries
and most of this aid will be focused
will it on those countries
who are receiving um most of these
people
that's correct both for those displaced
inside ukraine and the concern now is
that up to seven million people will
eventually uh sadly be displaced
in ukraine if this crisis continues
and up to four million people could flee
ukraine into neighboring countries and
beyond
the dec appeal will target and help the
most vulnerable communities in
particular women and children who seem
to be the worst affected by this crisis
both inside ukraine and in those
surrounding countries
okay salah saheed of the disasters
emergency committee thank you very much
indeed for being with us and good luck
with the appeal
thank you
right it has been day eight of the
invasion here another violent day
coming up next in the next hour
the latest from here as president putin
says his special operation his special
military operation
is going to plan
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you